so we're going to do uh something with
that looks really complicated it's
something like if you talk about math
you go oh no that looks horrific then
we'll see how it turns out okay
yes we've done it that is
probably the most horrific
equation we've ever done on number five
but what does it mean well let's try
this out we're going to plot it right
we're going to draw a graph in my
computer here and now i'm going to draw
the graph and it should be let me make
that bigger for you it's the equation
batman deserves but not the one he needs
right now
there go that is the batman curve it was
famous when it went viral last year a
high school teacher designed this curve
this equation so that it would draw the
batman logo and he made it quite
cleverly out of different curves and
straight lines can i show you how he did
it so here we've got film some things
that you may be familiar with straight
lines we can are quite easy to draw what
he did though is we don't want a circle
for batman we want an ellipse has a
slightly different equation so it looks
like that
now he turned this into his batman wings
obviously
we don't want the whole thing that's not
what the curve looked like he actually
just used these two ends he found a way
to multiply
his equation and the effect
was
it hides some of the curve what happens
here in this bit that's missing
this becomes a
complex number imaginary number which
means you can't draw it and that's what
he did he just carried on doing that he
just used curves and straight lines let
me show you what they look like to make
his batman now he used six curves let's
have a look at them so he used the
ellipse
i know this is quite clever this is the
bottom of the batman's symbol
these straight lines and these ones are
going to form his ears very pointy ones
there and then there goes some more
curves that finishes off the picture you
put it all together
and that's what you get
that's the batman so he hid parts of it
using imaginary numbers yeah
using square roots which would turn some
numbers that he doesn't want to find
into imaginary numbers it was a very
clever way it's the same curves but now
you can see he's hidden some parts of it
you put those together and you put them
together by multiplying
so you put it together he multiplied
these equations together what do you get
the batman curve it went viral last year
but i wanted to do it because i'm very
much looking forward
to the dark knight coming out don't like
rises